ja ich weiß was du vorhast handballer
und heute gibt es wieder nach ganz
langer langer langer zeit war
es ist zu wenig das die ganzen sommer
alle türen klappern und ganzen person
klappern geräusch machen also nicht
wundern
ihr fragt euch sicher wahrscheinlich
schon warum ich weise hat te laar
wilders ist damit ich den tisch nicht
richtig denn nach einigen wochen
probiere heute super sand aus dieser
super sein verspricht ein dass man super
tolle sachen modellieren kann und dass
der weich ist aber auch hart wird und
immer wieder weiß wird und hart wird und
jetzt möchte ich es ausprobieren
kombination die hände waschen habe ich
gemacht in seinem öffnen aufhören kann
atmen zu lassen
deshalb muss atmen nicht mit wasser
mischen so spektakulär
von magix wir das mal rein
so jetzt ist wen atmen lassen
also der geruch ist echt bisschen wie
wenn man ihn sind händler haben geht zu
dieser move aus dem kleiderschrank
so wie ich der sand wir müssen ihn atmen
lassen also sand ist das jetzt nicht
wirklich wenn das so bleibt aber kommt
das große aber es fühlt sich richtig
geil
das fühlt sich so viel ich will jetzt
einfach mal versuchen was zu modellieren
also gucken ob es klappt ich hoffe mein
lieber sand hat jetzt gefragt mit wem es
jetzt erraten was ich basteln
ihr habt noch keine armen okay dass es
auch fest bleibt ist so witzig das ist
mein modell nummer eins guck mal mama
ich hab aus dem bast meine erste statue
damit zum nächsten
ich kenne es auch eine demo verbissenen
junge dame was möchten sie den verein
führt hintertürchen alles klar mache ich
ihnen doch gerne
jetzt habe ich alles gemacht was mich
ein schönes eis nein es ist nicht ok
kinder ihr wollten richtigen
zaubertricks sehen dann mache ich jetzt
so viel sand ich doch nicht so sparsam
sein
die gute alte polnische sparsamkeit du
bist echt so dass ostblocks mäßig was
man seinen kindern immer mit gibt sparen
für irgendwas jetzt versuche ich mal
einen tunnel zu machen
hey was das alles aushält ich hätte mir
als kind für ausgeflippt damals hätte
ich so eine masse gehabt auch nicht so
eklig wie knete knete immer noch als
verbrauch ab aber bei knet habe ich mir
noch so in erinnerung dass das so
schwierig war unfertig oder als kind
nicht so gerne machen
challenge completed habe ich gerade
gesagt dass der mensch viel aushält nein
und genauso schnell wieder platz machen
mal schneit es schon bald gibt es die
sünden challenge wer kann schneller
machen
die erste folge vom sommer noch gemacht
das finde ich viel es wird auf jeden
fall auf eine zweite folge und die
dritte und möchte sieht aus als auch in
oslip ähnliches wäre ganz gut tor das
sind sobald eine brücke hat diese folge
waren wir zu wissen
ich wollte den ball spielen lassen weiß
ja und jetzt nicht mehr darüber ob penis
oder was nein diesen bau wasser aber mit
dem burschen überfall stunde
das ist ja widerlich jetzt ist lassen
wir es leider an einem objekt wie sie
diesen film